we've got to talk about the left eating
itself over the Trump Russia situation
the left has split in a horrible way
check out my Twitter feed it is
absolutely nuts what is going on people
I don't know but who seem to I don't
know if they have shows or they're
they're developing shows they're
fighting with me they're fighting with
each other and it's all over Trump
Russia and the right not surprisingly
dismisses the entire Trump Russia
situation they're ideologically
committed to their guy I don't care
about the right right we're getting what
we expect from the right I want to talk
about the left
why has Trump Russia split the left into
those who email me and say I'm a
Democratic Party shill and those who say
David there are crazies on the Left who
think the entire Trump Russia thing was
made up out of thin air this is so
damaging and I want to try to unpack
while this is going on so why are there
some on the left who refused to
acknowledge even the possibility that
Russia and Donald Trump may have
coordinated or colluded well number one
there's a group on the left that feels
as though if Russia helped Trump it
contradicts the narrative that Bernie
got screwed by the DNC and my answer is
no it doesn't Bernie got screwed by the
DNC in the DNC primary aside from
Russian hacking or interference or
anything else Bernie was screwed by the
DNC if Russia and Trump coordinated it
doesn't in any way undo that and that is
something that is a false dichotomy it
is not black and white the way some on
the Left are pointing out and you've got
to separate yourself from that narrative
number two there are those who believe
Bernie was more likely to defeat Donald
Trump in a general election than Hillary
Clinton and they feel that if they
accept Russian interference it weakens
their argument in some way they may feel
that Trump Russia collusion excuses the
loss that Hillary Clinton suffered
you've got to separate yourself from
that whether or not Russian interference
or hacking flipped the election to Trump
there's so much more to the story than
that and
it doesn't make Hillary Clinton any
better of a candidate I mean you know as
well as I do Pat that I voted for Bernie
Sanders in the primary I voted for
Hillary Clinton in the general election
but I've been hugely critical of Hillary
Clinton I think she was not a good
Democratic candidate by any means but I
thought she was better than Donald Trump
if you believe that there is something
to Trump Russia
it doesn't prop up Hillary Clinton
you've got to disconnect yourself from
that false narrative now there are
others on the Left who believe that a
focus on Trump Russia is a distraction
from real issues real issues on which
the Democratic Party is in great part
failing I agree with you I agree with
you the Left needs to be using the
important issues of our time to build a
platform for the 2018 midterms and the
2020 presidential election but that
doesn't mean Trump Russia isn't a real
scandal that needs to be investigated
whether or not you have a platform for
2018 or 2020 you can still talk about an
investigate Trump Russia and talk about
it extensively and we've been talking
about the lack of a cohesive democratic
platform for 2018 and 2020 healthcare
economics taxation immigration education
the minimum wage why is it one or the
other Pat I don't get it it does seem
like on the left the conversation is
shifting from if there's any legitimacy
behind the Trump Russia scandal - how
much time should we dedicate to it and
there's no easy formula for that I mean
if you look back at Watergate overlapped
with the Vietnam War right a bit and I'm
sure back then there was criticisms that
the TV and news outlets weren't
adequately covering Vietnam because
Watergate was distracting from it and we
had the same situation going on now
people are dying in Vietnam why are you
talking about whether Nixon lied or
recorded someone in the Oval Office and
I think that this is damaging on two
levels
number one this is not the time for a
fractured left okay that in fact it's
hard to think of a worse time
for a fractured left that's number one
number two if Trump Russia is nothing
and it evaporates
you need something else to justify
asking people to vote for you in 2018
and 2020 and if Trump Russia is
everything and it leads to Trump
resigning or being impeached doesn't
matter whether you think that that's
likely or unlikely if Trump is impeached
because of Trump Russia
you still need a platform to explain why
now that Trump is gone why should
someone vote for you as a Democrat over
a Republican who arguably or maybe was
not involved in the Trump Russia scandal
so it's great to have healthy skepticism
of everything you hear in media and at
this point it is hard to be a healthy
skeptic and doubt that there is
seriously sketchy stuff happening with
Russia after all we now have in writing
the knowledge that Donald Trump jr. was
made aware that Russia was trying to
help his dad how much clearer doesn't
need to be before you before you'll
concede that there's something here and
the left has got to get it together on
this because this is just an implosion
they are devouring each other from the
inside out and I think that the right
approach to this is to take an
all-of-the-above approach because we're
going to talk about Trump Russia we're
also going to talk about health care and
net neutrality and the minimum wage and
issues that do matter to everyday
American every time we talk about a
story about how the Democrats are way
off on a particular issue I get people
saying David are you ignoring the Russia
scandal anytime we talk about what's
going on with Russia people say David
this is not the key story the key story
is corporate dens and how Hillary
Clinton was a disaster it's an
all-of-the-above approach there is
newsworthiness to all of these stories
the left has got to calm down because
you are destroying yourselves and I know
a lot of you think that you're great
independence because you're not going to
fall for the establishment or the
Democratic line on Trump Russia at this
point you're denying obvious realities
and you've got to figure it out figure
out how to wake up and get out of this
stupor a lot of this is being discussed
on our reddit discussion forum I invite
you to join us there at david pakman.com
slash reddit today's program is made
possible in part by Gamefly which is
sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over eight
new and classic games for xbox one Xbox
360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can also stream games
you don't even need a gaming console or
a computer because you can stream games
through your Amazon fire stick or Roku
box and then use your mobile phone as
the controller you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price never with due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a 30-day free
trial at Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included no
contracts and you can also stream the
games I think I mentioned that you can
also rent games through the mobile app
get a free 30-day trial for david pakman
show viewers and listeners and support
our show at Gamefly offer.com forward
slash TDP s